[Music]
hey you guys time for another book
review this is my tomes of tarot show
the book i'm talking about today
actually came out quite a while ago
and i can't promise that i'm not going
to spoil things outright
like i said i usually try not to but to
talk about the book you do have to talk
about some various plot developments
so if you don't want to know anything
anything about
anything that happens in this book then
obviously you need to
read the book and or see the movie uh
which came out in 2008 and then come
back
and watch this review because i'm gonna
talk about what happens in the book and
if you don't want to know any of that
then
you're gonna find out so so this book is
the ruins by scott smith
now scott smith i think he's probably
best known for writing
a simple plan which came out in 1993
which was like a crime thriller
and that was also made into a movie it
was very very well received
both the book and the movie and this is
his second book and this book didn't
come out until 2006.
so he takes a long time to write a book
is
what i'm saying which is kind of a shame
because even though i haven't read a
simple plan
um i feel like a lot of people have
talked about like how [ __ ] awesome
that book is i've seen the movie
but um a lot of people have talked about
how awesome that book is so i'm sure i
will eventually get around to it because
i'm pretty sure i've never read it but
the interesting thing about this book
is that i heard a lot of other people
talking about it you know there's a lot
of reviews of it on goodreads there's a
lot of people talking about it on you
know various other book review channels
but the weird thing about it is that i
saw the movie version
of this first without realizing i guess
that it was based
on this particular novel so i want to
get a little bit into that too like how
the
the book in the movie differed the movie
is actually pretty good it's like a and
scott smith also wrote the screenplay
for the movie so
he's adapting his own work so it's not
like somebody else took it and like
mangled the story or anything
but it made like a lot of changes that i
thought were kind of interesting or
strange but i can kind of see
why they made the changes that they made
in particular the movie i think i
watched it on
2b now that i'm thinking about it so
it's i don't know if it's on there
anymore
like as of you know this is a few days
before christmas
uh 2020. so i think i just watched it a
couple of months ago
so if you want to see it it's actually a
pretty decent movie jenna malone is in
it and
some other people like that guy that was
in that beatles movie i can't remember
what his name is right now
but uh yeah so it was a pretty decent
movie and it follows the story
kind of faithfully although
some stuff that happens to the
characters is like switched around and
you know there's various other things
like the ending is different
um so i might get a little bit into that
like as we talk about so like i said
there might be some spoilers in here so
if you don't want to know anything about
it then
you might want to check out and then go
either read the book or watch the movie
and then come back
so okay the ruins is basically
it's a pretty simple survival horror
story
in the sense that an aspect of nature
is the villain or the antagonist
but it's not like regular nature nature
uh it's there's some of that but there's
also kind of like heightened nature
let's
let's say it like that so basically our
characters
are it's two couples jeff
amy stacy and eric now i think jeff and
amy are both
med students and eric and stacey i can't
remember what they say but they're like
all college students and i guess they're
getting ready to graduate or they're
getting ready to have some big milestone
or whatever
um and they've decided to take a
vacation
to cancun so they've been in cancun
for a little while like a few days a
week something like that
and the first part of the book is kind
of you know the the first part of the
book is actually pretty brief and it
like kind of just talks about
you know the [ __ ] that they did and you
know what they've been up to and what
happens to them
now at some stage they're kind of
hanging out on the beach
and they meet this german dude named
matthias
and he's you know he speaks perfect
english so they kind of start hanging
out with him
and then they kind of start hanging out
with these uh
three greek dudes who they don't
they don't speak any english all they
speak is greek and nobody along with
them speaks
you know nobody none of our main
protagonists speak any greek so no
nobody knows like what the [ __ ] any of
them are saying but they basically call
them
pablo juan and don quixote
because they don't know their names so
that's just what they call them and uh
basically these are just like a bunch of
fun-loving
drunk ass greeks that it's just you know
they're going around with backpacks full
of tequila and whatnot
so they're all kind of having a good
time now it comes to pass
that matthias has come to mexico on
vacation with his brother heinrich
now he tells our main foursome
that matthias met this like hot lady
archaeologist
on the beach and has gone up to help
them
at their dig like there's some mayan
ruins that they have this archaeological
dig going at
and matthias is like you know heinrich
really needs to like get his ass back
here because you know we're supposed to
fly back to germany you know in a few
days
and i haven't heard from him and he
hasn't come back so i need to go and
look for him
so everybody decides wouldn't it be a
cool
idea to go to this archaeological dig
and see these
mayan ruins which are apparently like
some undiscovered mayan ruins or
something like that because obviously
there's archaeolog
archaeologists there and it's kind of a
big deal so
our four protagonists and one of the
greeks
pablo decides to accompany matthias
to these ruins in the mayan jungle
to try to find his brother and also to
kind of have like an adventure
so they basically start going out
into the into the countryside
like they get a guy who you know gives
him a ride out there there's this really
really remote like
mayan village and the people they're
acting really weird they're like just
like kind of staring at them it's like
they don't
i don't know if they actually don't
understand what they're saying or
they're just pretending not to
so basically they get out of this truck
this guy has given a ride and he
doesn't really speak much english either
but he says to i amy i believe
um hey that's a bad place you don't want
to go there
but she doesn't really like she's like
you know she's like weirded out but then
she's kind of like
you know it'll be all right whatever so
what ends up happening is that they go
like down this trail
and there's this hill and it has all
these gorgeous
vines with these really really pr pretty
red flowers
on them now amy is trying to take a
picture of the whole group like look at
this cool adventure we're on in mexico
or whatever and while she's
taking the picture she's like backing up
to get everybody in the picture
and her foot basically goes up on this
hill that has all these vines on it
at which point a bunch of the mayans
like from the village
kind of encircle the hill over the
source and they start
like shooting at that like they all have
bows and arrows and guns and stuff
so they basically heard this group of
tourists onto this hill and they won't
let them leave
like so the mayans like they set up
camps like all around the perimeter of
this vine covered hill
and will not let them leave like they
threatened their threat they set up
little camps they got fires and
everything and little tents and whatnot
and basically they just sit there and
watch them like in shifts
like 24 7 and they will not let them
set foot off of this hill so
once the gang discover that the mayans
are not going to let them leave the hill
they go up the hill and discover that
there is
a um what looks like the remnants of the
archaeological dig like at the top of
the hill
there's kind of a big shaft like a mine
shaft
and then there's a um like a thing with
like a wind glass you know what i mean
with a
with a rope hanging down and they can't
but they can't find anybody there's a
couple of
tents there but one of them's kind of
torn up there's a bunch of backpacks
with [ __ ] in it like clothes and
notebooks and [ __ ] but there's nobody
around so everybody's like huh i wonder
what happened there
so they don't really know what happened
you know what i'm saying so at this
stage
they're kind of freaking out a little
bit and
it comes to pass that they hear a noise
down
in the mine shaft that sounds like
a cell phone now i can't remember the
reason exactly like one of why none of
their cell phones are working
like i think it's like it wasn't charged
or somebody left it or something like
that there was like some excuse and like
i said this was 2006 when this book was
written so it's not like
you know a lot of people have cell
phones but they weren't as ubiquitous i
guess as they are nowadays
so they think they hear a cell phone
ringing down in the shaft so they decide
that they're going to
that one of them is going to lower
themselves um down into the shaft to try
to find the cell phone so they can call
for help
um you know have a helicopter or some
[ __ ] like that like come to rescue them
because the mayans won't let
won't let them leave this hell while
they're uh doing that which seems like a
good idea
the rope breaks it's it's been sitting
there for like a long time but then it
seems like
the vine is kind of like around it and
then it kind of
burns through like it has this acidic
sap or whatever and so the rope breaks
and pablo with the greek guy he falls to
the bottom of the shaft
and ends up breaking his back
so then one of the other guys eric has
to lower himself down there
and um they have to figure out what's
going on he actually ends up because the
rope's not long enough and then he
actually ends up
injuring his leg like on the way down as
well so things just get
progressively shittier from there as i
said
this is this would be bad enough that
you're just like stuck on this hill
you know with a dude that's injured and
they can't move him obviously because
his
back is broken they don't really have
any supplies other than
you know just like a day or two's worth
of stuff like they had a bunch of water
they had some
tea they had a little bit of food like
some protein bars and [ __ ] like that
but you know nothing like they didn't
have like a lot of camping supplies or
anything now there were some supplies
like at the
campsites that they found but not enough
[ __ ] to like sustain you for very long
so as i said this would be bad enough
if just this if just this one guy was
injured
you know and then the other guy was
injured and they can't get off the hill
because otherwise they'll get shot
but then it turns out as the book slowly
unfolds
that there's some that there's something
very unusual about these
vines that cover the hill
now as i said if you don't want to know
anything about what the deal with these
vines is
then check out now because i'm going to
say what it is
so basically these vines are
it's never really explained which i
think is actually good because
if you found yourself in this situation
like if you're just up on this hill and
these vines were doing this [ __ ]
you wouldn't know like what the
explanation was because it's all
kind of from their point of view so
they never really say what these vines
are or
like how they evolved or what you know
what exactly
but the thing about it is that they
almost seem like a sentient
organism in the sense that
i mean the first things that they do
they they're flesh eating for one thing
um so they basically if there's a body
or something because they do find some
bodies later on of like some of the
archaeologists and stuff
um it'll just eat the flesh right off
your bones and just leave the bones
there
and it drinks blood it drinks vomit like
any kind of like organic material like
if you throw up or something because a
couple of the
characters do then the vine like will
send a tenderloin like drink it
so it feeds on uh organic material
and as the story goes on you also
discover
that the vines can pre-plan
they can they seem to be like
aware of what the people are thinking
and like how best to get to them
it can also mimic sounds and voices
and things of that like perfectly so it
can do all this kind of stuff and it
sounds
dumb like when i say it out loud like
that
but when you're reading it it's not dumb
it's actually like
really really creepy and you know what i
mean so i feel like because i read like
a bunch
of reviews of this and this is another
book that seems like it was either
you know i love it five stars or this
was stupid one star
so i think a lot of your enjoyment of
this book has to come from how
well you can suspend your disbelief if
you do not believe
that there are these vines and they are
you know
sentient and have like a human-like
intelligence can
mimic people's voices and stuff is to me
it didn't seem
all that absurd because i mean plants
can do some weird [ __ ] and like
animals can do weird [ __ ] so i was just
kind of like oh okay so i'm rolling with
it
um some people said oh it's like little
shop of horrors or whatever but it's
like
it didn't strike me like that at all i
think it's because
the way this is written it's interesting
because
it's a fairly long book it's three about
370 pages
more or less and there are no chapter
breaks it just kind of goes i mean every
now and then there's like a little break
you know what i mean where there's like
an extra space and like a drop cap or
whatever
but it's not like a different chapter so
it just kind of goes
you know through the whole thing without
really you know having any major
stops and it kind of switches back and
forth
from chara from character to character
so you're kind of inside the heads
of you know all four of the americans
and also of matthias never of pablo
though because i guess
you know he doesn't speak any english so
i guess we're not
we're not one plus he gets wounded like
almost immediately like when they get up
on the hill so it's like he's kind of
unconscious or [ __ ] up like most of
the time so we don't really know what
he's thinking about
but it kind of just drifts back and
forth between the perspectives of all
four of the characters
now it's interesting about this because
at first
the characters come across as other than
mathias
the american characters come across as
not i didn't find them
assholic necessarily like so i've seen
some reviewers say that they thought
that they were
and they didn't strike me as
particularly idiotic i mean they did
do some dumb [ __ ] but it was dumb [ __ ]
that
i can see people doing like it was
realistic dumb [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
like some of the [ __ ] they were thinking
about like they were trying to
you know deny what was happening then
and that kind of thing which seemed to
be a very
realistic response so but the
interesting thing was that i think at
first the four characters kind of just
blurred together like i couldn't really
tell one from the other
but then as the story goes on like each
one starts to develop their own distinct
personalities you spend more time with
them and you spend more time inside
their heads and i think that was kind of
a cool way to do it this is a very
deliberate book i mean this takes place
over the course of a few days
and it's pretty much all
i mean other than a brief prologue where
they're still you know they're on the
beach and they're thinking about their
vacation and stuff
once they get to the hill and they get
up on the hill the whole thing
is set on top of this hill with these
vines and it's just basically a struggle
for survival
um you know they don't have that much
food they're pretty much
okay for water because you know they're
in the jungle and it rains like all the
time and they're like
you know rigging up things to catch
water and stuff but they don't have a
lot of food and they have to ration it
out
and then they have to contend with the
mayans you know they can't
get down the hill you know they can't
escape because they've made like this
circle all the way around and they're
always watching them
and then they have to contend with the
fact that they
that these vines are doing this [ __ ]
that vines should not be able to do and
there's like some denial there and stuff
so i think that was like a really good
way of doing it
so like i said this is a very this is
one that
i didn't because i i think i say a lot
on
some of my reviews that you know i just
sat down and i read the whole thing in
one sitting
this one for some reason took me a while
to get through not because it was boring
or not because anything like that
it's just because the pace of it is so
deliberate in the sense that the the
horrific
events just keep ratcheting up slowly up
and up and up and it just keeps getting
worse and worse and worse
and worse and it's almost kind of like
if you sit and read it for too long
it just starts to really bum you out you
know what i mean
because this is a bleak ass book now
it's just descending toward this
inevitable conclusion
and it's just as as it goes on you can't
imagine
that there's going to be any escape from
this it's like this how are they going
to get out of this because like i said
it just keeps getting worse and worse
and worse like as it goes
and you know as the extent of the vines
abilities like become clearer and
clearer you're just like there's just no
way
you know there's no way to escape
there's no way to get away from it it's
really really bleak and like i said when
you're inside the people's heads and you
can
and you can kind of like feel their
struggles like and
and the different things that they're
going through like how they're trying to
deal with this
just crazy like impossible situation
that there's really no way out of
and it's just so it just keeps getting
like just bleaker and bleaker
and i will say too that this book is
also very
very gory very graphic the movie is
actually pretty gory too
there is [ __ ] in this where i mean
because some of the [ __ ] that the vines
can do like the vines will just
like like i said they're flesh eating
they can get inside
your wounds and like you know just like
tendrils up inside the body so there's
there's [ __ ] like you know legs getting
amputated there's people
flaying their own skin off there's like
that kind of stuff
so if gore's bothers you if you're if
gore bothers you please do not read this
because it's like it starts out
you know pretty tame but then it just
gets
like more and more gory like as it goes
on
and is everything is just like
disgusting
but disgusting like in a realistic way
like this is [ __ ] that
if you were somehow like put in a
situation like this and like i said i
can understand
if you know somebody was like you know
oh what intelligent vines yeah i don't
think so but
if you just kind of let it if you just
let it be
that like i said because some plants do
weird [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's not that crazy i didn't find it
that crazy like the premise i didn't
find it that
unbelievable yeah it probably would
never happen but
it wasn't so outlandish that it took me
out of it
i mean i was like really into it i was
totally buying it too like when that
when it got
to the point where the you know near the
end where like the vines started
imitating their voices
and like imitating other sounds and
stuff i was just kind of like oh well
that's
of course that's that's the next
horrible thing that it can do you know
what i mean
so it wasn't really like that
unbelievable
um but yeah so i want to talk a little
bit a bit about too
they made a movie out of this um i think
it was like an american australian
co-production like i said the movie came
out in 2008
and i actually wish this kind of sucks
because i actually wish that i had read
the book
before i saw the movie because as i said
when i saw the movie i just heard
somebody else talking about oh this is a
good movie
instead of like the yucatan and like
it's you know pretty gory and [ __ ] up
and so i watched the movie without
really realizing that it was based on
the novel
so then like now that i'm reading the
novel and i was just kind of like so i
almost so i already kind of knew
what was gonna happen like so there was
no mystery like leading up to
the hill and like why the mayans were
keeping them there and
you know what the [ __ ] what was going to
happen with the vines and stuff i mean i
saw the movie like
long enough ago that i didn't really
remember all of the little details
but i do wish that i could have come to
the book fresh
you know not knowing anything about the
vine or
the vines or like what they could do or
anything like that so
that is kind of one regret but it's
that's not the book's fault you know
that i
ended up seeing the movie first now
interestingly
um and like i said this this is kind of
a spoiler well
it's not kind of a spoiler it is a
spoiler but interestingly in the movie
they let one of the characters
survive which i can understand why
they do that because like i said
sometimes you can't do [ __ ] in a movie
that you can get away with in a book
with a book you can just be
totally bleak and [ __ ] depressing and
just like yeah we're just gonna kill
everybody because that's what would
really happen
but i can see that in a movie which
usually
i mean generally reaches a wider
audience than a book does
by a quite a large margin so you're
gonna get a lot
more blowback if you make a movie that
just has like the worst like
ending that makes you want to kill
yourself so i can see
why scott smith opted to you know it's
the the end of the movie isn't like i
wouldn't call it a hopeful ending
but it was certainly like a little bit
more
of a happy happy ending
you know with air quotes uh than the
book
was because the book ending was real
it was a real part i'm gonna say that
right now
so basically if you really like gory
survival horror like i said it's a very
simple primal
story it's just a bunch of people who
are kind of
not equipped for this [ __ ] who end up in
the middle of the jungle
and are not prepared for it and then not
only have to
contend with that with like a human
threat but they also have to contend
with
this crazy
vine like a series of vines that like
knows what they're thinking and like can
you know anticipate their moves and like
can
do really horrible [ __ ] so if that
sounds like something that you'd be into
then probably you should read although
like i said if you've gotten this far
you've probably already read it and if
because i just spoiled most of it for
you but
if for some reason that didn't dissuade
you
then uh definitely check it out like i
said
the ruins scott smith same guy who wrote
a simple plan
which i will eventually get around to
reading as well
i don't know why he doesn't write more
novels i guess he's got other [ __ ] to do
but
honestly it's like if you're gonna only
write a
you know a novel every you know 13 years
or something like that
at least make him really really good
ones and i do it does seem like he has
succeeded in doing that
so you know we'll give him that much
anyway but yeah so
it's a really really good book i really
do recommend it but not for
not for people that are real squeamish
or or anything like that but
survival horror for sure if you love
that kind of stuff then you will
probably really dig this book
so that'll do it for this review and
i'll see on the next one
bye